the FBI is investigating after a
passenger attacked a delta flight
attendant in midair the flight attendant
and another passenger were hurt in this
incident
it happened on this Boeing 767 jet last
night other passengers intervened right
away to stop the man the flight was
heading from Seattle to Beijing the
pilot turned around landing back in
Seattle after the assault Jamie yuccas
is in Los Angeles with how one passenger
says he tried to help Jamie good morning
good morning the situation could have
been a lot worse if it wasn't for the
actions of the other people on the plane
the flight had been in the air for about
45 minutes when a passenger in first
class assaulted a member of the crew
these are some of the passengers who are
on Delta flight 129 waiting to get to
Beijing after their plane was forced to
turn around mid-flight they returned to
Seattle after a 23 year old Florida man
in first class started acting agitated
another passenger who did not want to go
on camera saw what happened next
he spoke with reporters Natasha Chen
with CBS Seattle affiliate Cairo room
and then he started going towards the
exit door where a flight attendant tried
to subdue him where she got punched and
then another guy came in tried to help
and he got drilled to this situation
escalated quickly and they broke two
bottles of wine on his head and then
scuffle broke out we used the cart
pushed against him and then we tackled
him we tried to choke him and he just
threw me off like a rag doll and then we
zip tied him and moved back here even
passengers back in coach knew the
incident was serious we could see the
scuffling going on one of the flight
attendants ran back and said there was a
code three there was a serious flight up
front the flight attendant was injured
trying to subdue the passenger and she
got hit twice and she had some cuts and
her jaw was hit and then the other guy
that got hit in the head he was bleeding
the alleged assailant was arrested they
rolled the guy out he was a handcuffed
speeding and
found in a wheelchair now two people
were transported to the hospital the
remaining passengers were rebooked on
another flight to Beijing late last
night the man himself will be in court
later on today and we do know from
witnesses that he really was focused on
that emergency door he kept saying Norah
that he needed air he's scary Jamie
thank you so much